hi i'm dolly parton and today i'll be
doing the wired auto complete
interview i
don't google myself because i pretty
much know what i'm up to and if i
don't know all i gotta do is pick up a
national enquirer magazine
yeah right now let's see what the
internet is
asking first question is is dolly parton
a soprano
you mean mafia no but if you talk about
my voice
i would say i'm a soprano that means
very high
and i'm a very high singer the next
question
is is dolly parton country music
well absolutely i'm a country girl and i
started out in country music that's my
favorite
of course i like to think that i can do
all sorts of music
now i've been accepted all over the
world i've had
several pop records and all sorts of
styles but i'm a country girl so yes i'm
country music
no doubt next question is dolly parton
godmother to miley cyrus
well everybody knows that i actually say
i'm the fairy godmother
of miley cyrus is dolly parton
still magnolia i think i'm a still
magnolia
strong as steel my faith and pride like
so many good strong
women i really relate to that as a
matter of fact
i wrote a song called eagle when she
flies
for that movie they didn't use it but it
has lines like
gentle as the sweet magnolia strong as
steel her faith and pride
she's an everlasting shoulder she's the
leaning post of life
and i'd like to think that's who i am so
i am definitely a still magnolia
the next question is dolly parton
married
well yes i am married i have been
married for 54 years
this year 2020 and i have been with my
husband for 56 years we dated for two
years before we married
so we've been together most of our lives
and we're still happy can you believe
that
next question is who dolly parton
well i don't know dolly parton's a whole
lot of things i'd like to think that i'm
good friend a good daughter
a good aunt a good sister
and i love my fans so i'm just all kinds
of things
i'm a girl many colors who does dolly
parton look like
well a clown
well actually patterned my look after
what they called the town in my
hometown when i was a little girl
this woman that used to walk the streets
had all this makeup and hair high-heeled
shoes and
i thought she was so beautiful and
everybody used to say oh
she ain't nothing but trash and i used
to say well that's what i'm going to be
when i grow up
trash and that's kind of how i look but
i like to think i'm a little more than
that
question who did dolly parton write
songs for
well i always write songs for everybody
i know a lot of people out there have
all these feelings and they're not as
lucky as me to be able to have the gift
of rhyme
or to be able to sing songs and write
songs so i write for myself
but i write for you as well moving on to
the next search which is what dolly
parton
what is dolly parton up to
well i'm up to my neck and work right
now i've got a new christmas album
called a holly dolly christmas and it's
starring all sorts of great singers and
great people
like jimmy fallon michael buble miley
cyrus
willie nelson billy ray cyrus my brother
randy rhonda darren vincent lord i just
got all kinds of people on this album
and i hope you're going to enjoy that
too next question what is dolly parton's
favorite color
well you know what my favorite color is
a no color
it's white i love to wear white when i'm
performing on stage
it just makes me feel like all light and
airy
so it's a no color but i do love all
colors
what is dolly parton's favorite food
well that's easy potatoes every diet
i've ever
fell off of it's been because of a
potato either french fries
or mashed potatoes or baked potatoes
potato potato potato
i never met a spud i didn't like what is
dolly parton's hair
color black and white
actually my little nephew said that
about my sister stella
he was in school and the teacher was
asking the different children what color
is your mama's hair
when say brown or red and my little
nephew said
black and white and we got such a kick
out of that because my sister stellar
like me
even though her hair is not black we do
have her hair blonde so it looks very
dark at the roots
but i'm actually a dirty blonde i just
keep it bleached i started bleaching it
early but i was born whiteheaded i was
kind of a cotton top
when i was little what was dolly
parton's first song
well the first song actually was before
i started writing
is before i could write it down i was
about five years old i had a little cobb
doll that mama made me and i named her
tiny tassel top
because she had corn tassels for hair so
i wrote a little song
little tiny tassel top i love you an
awful lot hope you never go away
i want you to stay
but i started writing songs when i was
young and my first
record was called puppy love when i was
10 years old
next search is can dolly parton
can dolly parton cook and you better
believe it
i'm a really really good cook i'm not a
gourmet cook
my food is not pretty but it's good i
cook like my mom
my grandmas and my aunts i'm still one
of those people that really can cook
like the old days
that soul food cooking and that's kind
of i like best i can't eat it all the
time
anymore because it does have a lot of
calories in it
but yes i love to cook and yes i can
cook
can dolly parton still sing lord i hope
so
got a new album out singing every day
actually i try to sing all the time and
they say if you keep your pipes all
cleaned out you can always sing and i
try to always stay busy
so if i ever could sing i still can
can dolly parton yodel i guess i can
literally everybody can do that one
right
actually i kind of have a form of a
country yodel that i do
like incorporated in different songs
like a song i had out years ago called
mule skin or blues and
i kind of yodel at the ends of some of
the songs i'm not a true yodeler like
that kind of sound where they really do
that from the
swiss alps not that kind of yodeler but
i can go to them
next search is does dolly parton does
dolly parton
do concerts well i have been doing
concerts
all of my life for the most part and
i have not toured for the last couple of
years
of course nobody's touring right now but
i do
love to be in concert because i love
that feeling i get from my audience that
energy and that love we kind of
swap off to one another and i have to
say
although i have not been in concert
lately i really miss it
and can't wait to get back to where i
can actually have some interaction with
my fans
does dolly parton drink coffee yes i do
and i drink tea
as well but i'm one of those people i
like to get up in the morning
tumble out of bed and stumble to the
kitchen pour myself a cup of ambition
and usually that ambition is a cup of
coffee i'm good
with a cup and a half of coffee every
morning after that
i'm ready for the day does dolly parton
write her own
music well i write the biggest part of
it
i do record outside songs and i really
love other people's music but i do love
to write so i write a big part of it
does dolly parton have a new album well
yes i do
it's a christmas album it's called a
holly dolly christmas
what else how corny is that right or
cute i thought
anyway i've always loved the song a
holly jolly christmas
and i thought well i'm doing a christmas
album i need a good clever title
and i thought that was just perfectly
appropriate
well thank you internet for all those
questions i hope maybe you learned
something
and i hope i answered them properly for
you if not we'll do it again sometime
and i'll fix it